I'd like to welcome everyone back for
the afternoon portion of our program I
think we had a wonderful morning and
hope that we'll be able to talk about a
lot of the ideas that I know have come
up throughout the course of our
different sessions and presenters for
those of you who don't know me my name
is Pamela Graham my work here at
Columbia libraries as the director of
our global studies division and director
of our Center for Human Rights
documentation and research if you've
looked at our program carefully we hope
that the logic behind the sessions has
become evidence we heard from our
colleagues this morning about some of
the broader trends in higher education
about faculty research practices and
habits and then we had a chance to hear
from our own faculty about their work
and their insights so this afternoon
we're turning to academic libraries and
we've invited two colleagues to come and
share their experiences with us and in
terms of format will have both of our
speakers present and then open the floor
to your questions and comments the last
15 minutes of our program today are
slotted to be time for reflective
discussion I think is how we described
it so my hope is that we could kind of
organically roll from our
question-and-answer into that last
segment and I'll try to do my best job
this year us in that reflective
direction toward the end so let me
introduce our two presenters for this
session Martha brar is ahead of
collections research and instructional
services at the charles e young research
library at UCLA I hope you collected
either the books or the fines that our
faculty member on your library
Marta holds an MBA from the University
of Arizona and a PhD from the history of
consciousness program at UC Santa Cruz
she was a clear Council on library and
information resources fellow
postdoctoral fellow and through that
program she began working at UCLA in
2006 I'm also pleased to introduce Tracy
gavage who is the department head for
liaisons for departments labs and
centers ldl-c at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology libraries she's
both an engineer and a librarian holding
bachelor's and master's degrees in
engineering and has worked as an
engineer for ATT bell laboratories and
lucent technologies and after that
career she entered the world of academic
libraries in two thousand she also holds
an mms in library and information
science so very pleased to have both of
them here as i said we'll have both of
them presents and then we'll open the
floor for your comments and so we'll
start with um Marta well thank you for
inviting me to come and participate in
this really exciting day of discussion
and I'm delighted to tell the story of
one of the exciting things that's been
going on at UCLA library there's a lot
of exciting stuff going on there um so I
also wanted to note that the timing of
this is really wonderful because I'm
being asked to talk about two positions
that we created about two years ago and
almost exactly two years ago I presented
what we anticipated these positions
would be at the future of the library
symposium that was held at McMaster
University and sponsored by the library
journal so um the postings were only
just posted at that point and so I was
talking all in the future what we
expected so I'm really glad for this
occasion to riff
done how it's been going and get some
more feedback now that you hear what
we've been up so I'm going to be
focusing on the research library UCLA
the charles e young research library
which supports research and instruction
in the humanities Social Sciences and
area studies we also have special
collections east asian library and a few
other departments in that library and we
had a major renovation project from
about two thousand six until 2011 it
involved two of our floors the lower
level the a level and the first floor
which is the ground floor that you come
in on and it took what by all accounts
was a dreary mid twentieth century
interior and heard it turned it into
something open and lively and upbeat
inspiring kind of place and it's really
become a destination in a way that it
wasn't before gate counts have doubled
doubled that's the one outstanding
statistic that everybody sites it's
almost always full now that wasn't the
case before especially the library
classrooms much to the chagrin of those
of us who would like to reserve them to
do an instruction group study rooms the
research comments are reading room
they're almost always full some of the
spaces got updates or reading room and
our circulation desk for example and
other spaces were completely new
including a research Commons study
Commons a cafe a group study rooms and a
new conference space which is the only
free conference space on campus I'll let
you draw your conclusions about what we
face as a result high-tech classroom
gets used all the time and there's a new
more robust laptop lending
services that we host so here are a few
pictures from the renovated spaces as
you can see it has an open feeling with
transparent walls spacious lobbies and
corridors it was designed around three
guiding concepts journey discovery and
collaboration those are physically
printed on the walls in various
strategic places it's meant to showcase
the process and the community of
research and not just the finished
products in other words that
publications and I think it actually is
doing that so I'm going to be speaking
from the perspective of one unit within
this library and that's my unit the
collections research and instructional
services unit which goes by the acronym
Chris and we are about 20 people of 10
or so librarians subject specialists in
the humanities Social Sciences and area
studies including government documents
and cartographic resources and we do
everything collection development
reference instruction um and we lived
through this renovation in a way that a
lot of other units did not did at first
it happened below us then they moved us
and then they happen above us we were
keenly aware that it was happening but
the the project management and design
issues were really handled at the
library administration level the
librarians and library assistants in our
unit were at the time that the
renovation really got underway were
longtime employees most had been there
at least 10 years and a good number of
them 20 plus 30 plus years that balance
has has tipped a bit in the direction of
newer career librarians but worse
will we still have an awful lot of
experience under our collective belts in
the course of the renovation retirements
and recruitment away from our department
coupled with the financial crash led to
major attrition this probably sounds
familiar to some of you and and this
prompted a reorganization process in our
department so we were really primed at
this moment to think about who is doing
what and why our collections and
operating budgets were cut numerous
vacancies went unfilled librarians and
staff experienced furloughs and more
work was spread across fewer people and
we're still having trouble figuring out
what not to do thankfully the library
administration didn't have to enact a
hiring freeze but those of us who were
in positions to make hiring decisions
and proposed new new physicians really
needed to get creative if we were going
to get campus administration to give us
those new positions we couldn't be
expected to just fill vacancies we had
to really present positions that were
well thought out and forward thinking so
when we grappled with the question of
how to fill vacancies in Chris we were
confronted with the renovation plans and
we began to think about what kinds of
librarians we would need to staff these
spaces and as mentioned by Roger and by
the faculty panel there are all kinds of
new research methodologies especially
digitally enabled and digitally
augmented research interdisciplinarity
and there's also a new pedagogy new
pedagogical practice including an active
learning service learning which isn't
exactly new but being used more and more
undergraduate Capstone's and so on and
so we needed to confront the question of
what kinds of librarians we would need a
to support these new approaches to
research and teaching and we realized
that new hires could explicitly be
tasked with figuring out these new roles
while the rest of us adapted more
incrementally because we were so busy
consequently these positions were
designed to prefigure the rules that the
rest of us would be playing over the
coming years we were able to get to new
positions approved the librarian for
digital research and scholarship and the
librarian for advanced research and
engagement these were completely new
unprecedented for our library at both
jobs job descriptions required a lot of
the planning revision outside input I
talked it a couple different conferences
about these positions and they also
required a lot of explaining within
Chris as you can imagine these positions
didn't go over well because they by all
accounts did nothing to relieve the
burden of all the work that the rest of
us had had to absorb from all the
departures and vacancies and so these
were very difficult conversations I'm
going to tell you first about the
librarian for digital research and
scholarship as OE borovsky our new LD RS
came on board about a month before the
new research Commons opened this was not
very much time for her to prepare I'll
tell you a little bit more about Zoey's
background in a moment but as you can
see it's not a traditional space this is
a sliver of what is actually a very
expansive room with little alcoves that
our research labs for digital humanities
and there is a digital sandbox area for
librarians and library staff to use but
it's not immediately intuitive what goes
on in this space and that's going to be
become important so the
students that prompted our thinking
about this position were what will go on
in this space who will use it how will
users get help when they need it there's
no reference desk or help desk in this
space which library unit or units would
own this space it was not a
responsibility for this space was not
given to any one unit um I knew that I
wanted to have a Chris librarian who
came to work thinking about this space
and that was part my prime motivation
for wanting to create this position if
only to ensure that the IT staff who
were dealing with the technology were
worth thinking about it in the context
of the research and teaching that would
be going on on this campus so in the end
this position description included
oversight of the research and teaching
support activities in the research
Commons as well as acting as liaison to
our new digital humanities minor and
graduate certificate program and subject
specialist with liaison responsibilities
in at least one other subject area on
anthropology as it turned out Zoey
actually came with expertise in
Scandinavian studies but we had a
Scandinavian studies will impair
handsome now after the renovated space
is opened with the start of the academic
year in the fall of 2011 it quickly
became apparent that one person could
not handle this space and that it would
take a team oversight because everything
was so new not all of the technology had
been installed yet no policies virtually
no policies had been created before we
opened so Zoe convened what she called
the research Commons working group and
this consisted of people from Chris from
our our instructional computing group
which goes by the acronym click our
library IT and people from the UCLA
center for digital humanities which is
outside of the library on our campus and
the research comments was put through
its paces in the first quarter alone it
was quickly populated with individuals
mostly undergraduates who were looking
for quiet study space so when they
looked at the picture or when they
walked into the research Commons what
did they see a seat that's what they saw
so the large screens that are in each of
the pots ignored them much to our
chagrin so um there was a lot of shashi
occasional scuffles not quite fisticuffs
but sometimes on the verge fights about
the culture of the space the library
invited a few key faculty members to
offer their courses in that space and
adjoining spaces which meant that we had
to kick out the drop-in users um there's
no door on the space it's wide open one
one side of it opens onto the cafe the
other opens on to this corridor that we
call the street so there's no way to
police people or shut the doors and make
them use a card swipe or anything and so
um the library also in the very first
quarter offered to host a 300-person DIY
days event some of you may be familiar
with DIY days I believe it's a movement
that Kent came out of New York City you
can google it at some to get more
information about it but it was an
unprecedented kind of event and it was a
very outward facing event it wasn't
about library stuff so it was it was um
it took a lot of selling and a lot of
hand holding that make it actually
happen so over the first year the
research Commons working group spent
most of its time troubleshooting details
we don't have an Events Coordinator in
our library so any planning for events
falls to the people
our closest to that event in terms of
their function within the library so
what we found just as an aside we're
doing a major assessment project which
I'll mention later but out of that we've
discovered that the kinds of activities
we anticipated having happen in their
collaborative research projects and so
on actually happened when there aren't
very many people there which means they
happen after five o'clock at night and
they happen on the weekends so we
actually weren't aware of those trends
until we started doing some assessment
over space and now we're starting to do
things differently like offering instead
of offering great big events in that
space trying to do some targeted small
group hands-on kinds of activities to
get people to be familiar with what's
possible in that space so all of this is
to say that the ldr s position was in
the danger of devolving from a subject
librarian position into a lab manager or
a tech support person in other words the
librarian element was in the danger of
getting lost in the shuffle and zoe has
had to work and still has had to work
constantly to define her position in
terms of librarianship in her previous
work we stole her from another unit on
campus and she had worked as academic
services manager to the center for
digital humanities and she supervised
lamin managers so she was very clear
about those functions and this sort of
hybrid background that she brought to
her position helped her to see
categories of functions within that
space you know the difference between
taking a reservation versus consulting
with a faculty member about the
pedagogical practices or the learning
outcomes that they were shooting for
that could be served in the research
Commons and I want to point to this sign
which I have on the left hand side of
this screen it
probably anak uist enough as a poster or
a sign that you would see somewhere but
this is a product of months of work and
I think it's brilliant and the brilliant
thing is that in one sign they were able
to do things that initially drove us
crazy um figuring out the culture
communicating the culture of the space
groups meet talk work explorer it's not
code for silent work what can you do in
this space you have access to big
screens laptop's wireless so that
gestures at the kinds of activities we
might expect to see happening here um
logistics yes you can reserve here's how
initially that was a big source of
confusion who gets these spots and if it
is you know the politics of well if
there's one person sitting in a pod can
I actually sit down beside them if I'm
not associated with them well now we've
got reservations and then connecting
people with the librarian all of that in
one sign I'll talk a little bit more
about the challenges of signage in our
renovated space and women but to get
back to the trap of the lab manager this
is the single biggest challenge for this
position and a Zoe puts it I asked her
to reflect on her experience with me
before I came here she said that the
trap of thinking of the librarian is lab
manager is the product of thinking of
the library as face so what she strives
to get all of us to do instead is to
focus on what students and faculty as
well as staff from other research units
on campus want or need to do with their
teaching learning and research and in
that way we have an opportunity to show
them what's possible and then draw them
into the space if that's called for but
that we're not just showing off the
space and saying isn't this cool
wouldn't you like to be here without
having that conversation about what they
actually need to achieve
okay so now I'm going to transition to
the second position the librarian for
advanced research and engagement and
Allison Benedetti came on board about a
year ago this was a much more slippery
job description for us to write it
expanded and contracted in scope several
times before it settled into the
position that we actually posted it
started out as a reading room reference
services coordinator then it expanded to
a UCLA library wide outreach librarian
and then it scaled back to what it
settled into which is the outreach
assessment and public services librarian
for the Chris department so be shifting
notions of what we needed in this
position had everything to do with the
fact that UCLA library has needed to do
a better job of reaching out to campus
and saying what we do and how we can
foster scholarly engagement with the
library changing research methods
evolving curricula prolific blur sorry
proliferation of electronic resources
and tools and the constricting economy
have all really converged to mrs.
necessitate a new role for the library
on campus this position did not come
with any subject liaison
responsibilities or collection
development responsibilities and again
as you can imagine this wasn't very well
received by other chris librarians
nonetheless our leadership team really
felt that this role would be difficult
to define and then this person would be
challenged enough with the task of
trying to define this role that we
didn't want her to also have to do the
collection development and the liaison
responsibilities at least initially we
wanted to really ramp up our assessment
effort
in a way that we just couldn't do
ourselves we really wanted to rethink
outreach in a way that those of us who
are carrying five or six subject areas
really couldn't do we needed somebody to
kind of take the lead on that and now
that Alison's been here long enough for
her position to become better
established we are at the point of
considering giving her a subject liaison
responsibilities because that may that's
a natural fit for her to try out some of
the things that she's that she's tried
to establish her biggest project to date
is the North Campus research community
study this is a multimodal participatory
design assessment project we've got a
team of four researchers including
myself and Allison Zoe borovsky and then
our head of Social Sciences are a team
leader rather of social sciences and
humanities Jennifer osorio and we'll be
presenting our preliminary results at
ACRL next month if anybody's going come
look us up along the way alison has also
been coordinating our reference services
and is really trying to rethink how we
offer those reference services and
support research for all cap campus
constituents the unprecedented and work
in progress nature of Allison's role has
made it more challenging than most roles
to inhabit she has more than most new
recruits had to get a really firm handle
on the professional and organizational
culture of UCLA library in order to
figure out which outreach efforts will
fly and which service innovations will
take more lead time to implement and so
on and in the initial weeks on the job
nearly every conversation that she had
with new librarians and her new
colleagues rather within the library and
she met with pretty much everybody most
of those conversations started out with
some variation on what exactly is your
zishan and we we pronounced the acronym
Larry so what is a Larry why are you
here and what are you supposed to be
doing and these questions communicated
at least reserved if not fear of what
impact or what is what does your
position say about my role is is the
fact that they hired you a criticism of
what I'm doing are you somehow going to
create more work for me I'm already
overworked these are the kinds of
conversations that she had by now Alison
is a some a few of you may know Alison
khushi that was on the East Coast here
for a little while before coming to us
but she's very well integrated and by
all accounts she's very well-liked still
her position as change agent um a really
concerned and tough place and she often
feels like the ideas that she offers for
improving our services and practices are
interpreted as criticisms rather than
interpreted as as helpful contributions
to our collective efforts to improve
what we do so her work is still viewed
by some as meta rather than core and
that's part of my job to try and help to
change people's perceptions of this role
because again the idea is that she's
doing she's doing and inhabiting the
rules that we are all going to be doing
and inhabiting as we are able so
embodying change is a hard place to be
it's a really hard position to be in so
Allison suggests that any libraries that
are considering similar recruitments
should look for individuals with
persistence thick skin strong
collaboration skills excellent listening
skills and the ability to listen to and
see multiple viewpoints understand and
appreciate where are those
they're coming from and then use that
understanding to figure out common
ground that forms the basis for
partnerships and just as an aside it
look if you want to discuss this in the
question and answer period Zoe brofsky
came to us with a PhD she's an other
degreed librarian and Alison came with
an mls and library experience I'm happy
to talk about any implications of that
later so I'm to sum up this chart
represents I presented this at McMaster
two years ago at the the future of the
academic library symposium and this is
what we expected these roles to be so
you can see that the orange in the
middle is what we expected both
positions to share qualities that they
would share and then the kinds of
activities that we anticipated they
would be most heavily involved in and
this is the reality the red bits are
what they've spent most of their time
doing and so we're hoping that as the
the growing pains are subsided now that
we can get them back to doing the things
that we had anticipated and and they may
even change some of the things that
they're doing because they of what
they're learning so uh the last thing
I'll just say before summing up is that
both positions are still works in
progress but we're very happy with the
way that they've turned out they've
really enriched our activities for all
of us in the department and
incorporating these two new roles in our
department has prompted a change in the
culture and I think that cultural
influence is spreading beyond the
balance of our department to other areas
of the of the library and that's from a
culture of perfectionism to a culture of
iterative change and experimental
implementation that's been really
important because we're having to try
out so much and we're having to find out
where we fail and what that signals what
kind of learning can come out of that
failure and this is really important
because they are still working out
librarian roles in for a future that's
not clear yet so thank you hello
everybody it's a pleasure to be here
little did I know 23 years ago when I
got my master's degree in engineering
from Columbia that I'd be back here
speaking to all view from the libraries
and it never crossed my mind so it's
great to be here to talk about a case
study of Holy Library System
reorganization something that we did at
MIT really beginning in 2008 and tell
you the story up into the present day
and I'm going to tell you the story from
the middle on the middle manager there
on my department head of liaison
librarians and I got a good view of both
the pain points and the victories from
the whole gamut of staff from senior
leadership to folks who serve the users
every day so the plan is i'll tell you i
was organized and how our reorganization
fits into a very particular
institutional culture of MIT and share
with you the timeline about how long
such a thing took us and may take other
institutions longer or shorter I don't
know and then specifically how we
changed and I'll give a glimpse into how
the thought about the liaison librarian
role since I know that one the best of
all and then where we stand today and
how some of the changes play out okay so
a little bit of context about MIT
because that is a big factor in the
story we have about 11,000 students it's
a medium-sized institution with about a
thousand faculty and as everybody knows
we're very focused in science and
engineering and that is about seventy
percent of our students are majoring in
those areas mit is a highly
decentralized place that's organized
into a group of five schools of which I
have them listed up here architecture
and planning engineering science
humanities arts and social sciences and
did I say management you know science
management olives so despite the and
actually the the power structure MIT
really rests with the department is the
department it's highly decentralized
however it has a very strong
institutional culture I would say of
qualities like innovation as you might
expect meritocracy risk-taking um it's a
very data-driven place it's focused on
teamwork and collaboration and it's an
intense place people are appreciative
and solve the world's problems that's
the smallest thing they think of doing
so the libraries it's funny being part
of libraries where we value the
long-term and think about things
carefully existing in a culture like MIT
so um it's it's fun and exciting so the
libraries that serve the institution you
have about 185 staff and give 20 million
dollar budget give or take a few million
I don't really track it on a year year
basis and the way we used to be
organized it think is fairly traditional
we used to have while we still have many
library locations we have four main
libraries if you will and or four main
library organizations five main
libraries locations and we were
organized according to those physical
locations which were created in
alignment with MIT school so the
engineering and science organization
with two libraries supported science and
engineering of course our duty library
supports the school Sloan School of
Management and etc we could see the
pictures and this old way of organizing
was supported by very traditional
hierarchies of head librarians for each
space associate heads clutch managers
subject specialists circulation local
processing the whole gamut with each
location and we all use a group of
shared services that were centrally
located around acquisitions licensing
technology supports interlibrary lending
etc but we knew that this was beginning
to constrain us way back in 2004 when we
created a strategic plan at the time
that acknowledged that in order to
embrace what was coming we could see was
coming we were starting to be hindered
by this organizational structure we can
do something about it so the seed was
planted I think that's a very important
point the seed was planted way back in
2004 even though we did nothing about it
until the next strategic planning cycle
started so um the changes that we're
seeing and compass still a lot of areas
and I'll go through a few of them first
of all the change in research I've
already said we were organized by school
our physical structure and organization
structure totally reflected this but in
fact it meant nothing at MIT in terms of
how work gets done and the way people
work together in fact the work is
incredibly multi-discipline
right and overlapping and it organizing
by school made no sense and we could see
that in our use patterns so we could
tell from survey and collections use
patterns that in fact many people use
many libraries because the materials
they needed standing span many
disciplines and you know we had we knew
from our survey that sixty-five percent
visited two or more libraries and even
forty percent visit three or more and
that it's our survey told us
eighty-eight percent of our users access
information from outside the library I
would argue that was a hundred percent
and they can say no those twelve percent
just didn't know they were using the
library resources so we had that
catalyst for change also it's true in so
many places this is the change our our
expenditures from 2003 to 2012 in terms
of what we spent on print versus
electronic we've shifted drastically and
this this was quite helped by budget
cuts let me tell you but that will
accelerate a occurred quite fast also
even though we're so focused on
electronic access and our community
values it so much we are keeping very
close tabs on how they use materials and
where they prefer print where they
prefer electronic materials and we
survey them regularly on what their
preference is for different kinds of
materials so we can focus our
collections more appropriately and while
on the blue side is electronic
preference the green side is print
preference and the this data is
transitioning over time to the blue side
but we still have quite a lot in the
green side so we need to we needed to
recognize that fact in reorganizing
additionally the spaces and the
libraries are very important to our
students on not living as much by
faculty as you heard from the faculty
panel and we are really we can see that
the needs for the spaces are changing
beyond what we traditionally offered and
this is a we believe in doing
ethnographic
studies and one that we did had to do
with space mapping we use GIS software
to map where the use of our libraries
were my keeper and what they were doing
in those spaces and it was a lot of
great research but we know that the
spaces were important and they are
highly used and our surveys support that
by showing you know sixty-four percent
of the people who responded do use our
spaces at least weekly but we knew that
the the space what we offer in our space
is actually doesn't match with what's
needed so we have some work to do and we
needed our organization to sip like that
so sadly at the same time as we were
getting ready to do this whole system
reorg we hit 2008 and the financial
crisis came upon us and we were facing a
15-percent budget reduction over to the
next two fiscal years which was both a
blessing and a curse is a blessing in
the fact that we were already in the
process of reorganization so we were
already being very thoughtful about how
we wanted to spend our how we wanted to
use our staff resources and collections
resources and it was a curse and that
forevermore the reorganization and the
budget cuts were completed in people's
mind so there's a lot of recovery you
have to do with that because
reorganization is painful even though I
feel very positive about it it's a
painful process for many people because
it's a wholesale change for everybody so
the process the timeline be followed is
that in 2008 we started the process
right before you know everything kind of
blew up in the fall and and we started
the strategic planning process with the
intention of starting a new plan with a
reorganized system so the creating the
plan helped us create the new
organization by April of 2009 we
finalized the plan by July we would be
baking about starting to make the budget
cuts ahead of actually figuring out what
the future organization was in 2009 they
we finished the high-level organization
chart
with key leadership roles defined and at
that point the planning went from the
senior leadership team to the department
heads essentially to engineer the
transition to the new structure by July
the following year we had moved
substantially into the new structure
with some parts yet to be completed
which we finished in early 2012 and in
these days were in a state of
evolutionary change we know that we
can't stay in this one model it's not
finished and we still need to respond to
changes that are ever occurring so this
I'm not sure you can read it but I'll
just kind of give you the conceptual
overview this was the the high-level
chart that was given to us in 2009 to
describe what we were after in our new
organization and the it's conceptual and
that is not a traditional hierarchical
org chart but it shows that the culture
we wanted to create was a culture of one
library system serving the needs of the
entire MIT community and we didn't want
to be location dependent and we wanted
to we did away with the terms of public
services and technical services which
were our old Directorate names and with
the idea that everybody served to the
users and we wanted to make this a very
user driven organization so the bulk of
the people in our organization are in
the the the right half of the circle the
research and instructional services and
information resources and then we have
information technology strategy
administration and our directors office
and I'll go into detail about what some
of the changes were but first we had to
get through some budget stuff and what
we did in that time as we closed our
last two science and engineering branch
libraries or aeronautics and
astronautics library as well as our that
aspheric and planetary science this is
library and merge those collections and
people into our engineering and science
libraries respectively we cut ours very
a very visible change and we've cut
collections of course
we did layoffs probably I don't remember
the exact number around 15 layoffs and
staff did two weeks of furloughs for a
couple of years so a hard time for sure
so but once we got past to that really
awful year we started into the changes
we really wanted to see and we created
some new departments and of course I'm
starting with my own the liaisons for
departments labs and centers where we
brought together all the subject
specialists into a single department and
i'll talk about them specifically more
specifically later we also created two
departments that support the work of
liaisons so we have one per instruction
and reference services and one for
collection strategy and management and
their small departments and their
purpose is to create policy and practice
around those activities and to support
the liaison librarians and carrying them
out so the instruction and reference
services group came up with an
instruction plan and then we're working
together to implement that plan so that
we have a common framework from which
liaisons can then individually you know
figure out how to best tailor it to
their communities we created a
department of specialized content and
services and this brings together a lot
of technologically intensive services
like research data management and GIS
and image support video support that we
have we have video production and
distance education within our library
system they're all within this
department and finding ways to think
about those services and common ways to
help each other out we and I'll note
also with this department that we have
taken away the expectations that liaison
librarians have to know everything and
then there's more to that that first big
section we brought together our
acquisitions metadata and enterprise
systems group into a single department
but did nothing else to it we just said
you know we're going to we're going to
handle this part later but we want to at
least get you into a single organization
at this point we created an office of
scholarly publishing a licensing which
is a fantastic success on the MIT campus
in terms of the recognition of the
expertise that's offered in terms of
publishing intellectual property open
access in those kinds of initiatives we
also create a team there's headcount
devoted to both assessment and marketing
in our new organization and we have
teams created around in the cross
departments that help us think
holistically about those activities and
to support the rest of us okay so now
we're on to part three a year and a half
later we've finally gotten past the
major budget cuts we've transitioned
most people into new positions and
activities at this point by early 2012
we've made a bunch of strategic hires to
enable us to focus more actively on
building up our digital infrastructure
around preservation conservation
archives a strategy around acquiring
digital content we have a new associate
director of Technology and then director
of research those those last you used to
be a single position and we've split
them out into two to enable us to
concentrate more effectively in both
areas our acquisition this is where the
acquisitions metadata and enterprise
people got into the action they had
decided they wanted to have some outside
expertise so we ended up hiring our two
consultants which I think many libraries
have worked with over the years and we
went with their recommendations where we
used to be organized by function you
know acquisitions and catalog
for instance we now are organized by
workflow so we've put together the team
that handles all aspects of tangible
formats and other team on TV your
sources etc and at this point we also
centralized administrative assistant
reboot the support we thought it was it
was time to do that given the size of
staff we had available okay so I'm going
to delve a little bit into the role of
liaisons and how we've been changing it
over time and I would say our old way of
thinking about liaisons I think of it as
the lone wolf model so we would hire a
liaison trained him up in our workflows
and procedures and then set them off
into the wild and they would be on their
own forging a program of librarianship
with their assigned communities and
subject areas and I would say that it
resulted in in many cases excellence of
liaison program and sometimes maybe not
so excellent you know liaison program it
was a quite a wide range and different
people were comfortable with different
aspects of the roles that they were
called upon to do and the focus was on
the traditional reference and
instruction so we changed the model to
be much more networked collaborative
model to take advantage of the strengths
of our various colleagues in this these
roles and we've built in many support
structures to enable them to not have to
invent the wheel for everything they do
reinvent the wheel for everything they
do but rather call my expertise of their
colleagues and and to create some new
models for instance you know I struck by
the the faculty panel today our history
library our history history of science
librarian and at the time of the
reorganization she proposed a split role
between being a liaison
my department and existing for part time
in the archives because she saw the
instructional opportunities and
possibilities with working with the
archives in instructing historic our
science historian students in research
methods that used primary source
materials as well as many other kinds of
materials so we were able to you know
create partnerships like that in this
transition so you know things aren't
perfect we designed some new
organization that optimizes aspects of
our work but of course when you optimize
something you're not optimizing other
things and i would say that we still
have yet to figure out things like
handling space we have this great UX
organization that we've created to think
about space and and virtual environments
but we haven't figured out the rest of
the organization to support it so you
know we still have to think about that
and to get the whole continuum from the
operational space concerns up to the
strategic picture of space in a good
functional set of working groups also we
so need to work on capacity because our
aspirations far outstrip our ability to
produce and I think about it in terms of
developments in the two contexts of
development both software development
because we really need the technical
capacity within the libraries and also
development from the fundraising
perspective that if it's not going to
come from the institution we need to go
find the money elsewhere to to make
things happen one thing that we
specifically did not optimized on and
broke the optimization on was the school
focused relationships when we have these
structures focused around schools the
head librarian typically had a very good
lationship well some of them did had
good relationships with the school
administrations and we broke that apart
really and we only have the same
capacity for building that kind of
relationship but it turns out not all
the schools really care about that
relationship but there are two that did
so at this point we need to figure out
how to build that in more appropriately
and and and get back to some of that
strong relationship split assignments is
another thing this the history librarian
that I told you who proposed a split
between departments so dual report into
two different organizations that one
works great because that employee is
motivated and can see the benefits of it
and bring them together an entire staff
into a new organization you don't always
have an exact match to skill set and
ability to the divisions that exist so
we do have a whole slew of positions
that report into multiple organizations
and no matter how how much work we try
to reduce the overhead associated with
that kind of thing some some staff are
just never going to thrive in that kind
of arrangement and some staff will so
over time we have to resolve the places
where it's a problem and still continue
to support the places where it works
really well and it's a continuous
learning experience for all of us and
then these last two they're just kind of
Givens no matter what you do again if
you optimize some relationships in
departments you're going to break others
so you still have to work on that
communication and relationship building
no matter what and we you know given
that we have reorganized there are still
changes yet to come that have come to
light because of the changes we've
already made so on special collections
for instance we realized now that there
are overlaps between what r KY
RSU archived dude and our specialized
contents and services group do so there
may be opportunities for bringing things
pieces of those work flows together and
organizations together to to create
better access and handling of special
collections also we have you know staff
vacancies always prompt a little
introspection to how you think about the
organization we have one of our
department heads from user experiences
left and it's prompting us to think
about is having a department the right
way to think about it or are there other
models that might soar that mean even
better so it's an example of the kind of
thinking want to keep doing as as you
learn from what's presented in a new
organization and so the things that are
working for us is we still provide great
service if I do say so myself um we
provide a very responsive organization
people continually tell us how happy
they are to get a human being when they
want them and that they can get plenty
of help on their own when they don't
want to interact with the human being
they love the instantaneous access to
the materials we provide and like our
focus on going digital our ability to
focus on strategic initiatives and hire
people to support our digital
infrastructure has been a big success
the one library approaches worked great
so in that old siloed organization we
had we started seeing a variety of
service models creep up in each location
and our users who use multiple libraries
got confused by you know one thing they
could do here versus not there and they
didn't like that too much so I think
that our approach
one librarian to help that perception
quite a bit also we're better able to
focus on institutional priorities and I
will give an example about that and it
has to do with move madness which we've
heard about of its already um MIT jumped
into the movie game last spring last
year spring with its first class and has
since formed with Harvard the edx
initiative and and it has been named by
our president any president rafael rice
as an area of high strategic importance
to figure out how we're going to involve
evolve pedagogical approaches using
digital learning so when they when MIT
thinks about MOOCs it knows about this
external ability to educate the world in
these digital learning ways but this
really focused on the change that it's
going to enable in the on-campus
experience and they're eager to figure
out how to flip the classrooms and
explore those models and do research
around this so the way it affects the
library's if your president says we're
going to change the pedagogical
experience you know we needed to be
involved so um so from the very
beginning he created an initiative
around this a strategic initiative and
involved in the library system we
brought together people to work on it
and we've done extensive outreach around
the campus tying in to the different
organizations that are thinking about
this and finally it's coalesced into a
single organization with a head so it
actually becoming a little simpler now
but at first it was the Wild West and
they're laying the train tracks as the
train is running and
it was chaotic so but this aggressive
outreach has been very helpful to to
such an extent that now the library ISM
are involved with the thinking that's
going on about how teaching and learning
spaces ought to evolve to support the
flipped classroom on campus and we're
involved in thinking about how to teach
research skills in a digital learning
context whether it's for external
students or on campus students we have
been asked to to think about housing the
learning analytic data the data that's
going to fuel the learning analytics
somewhere within the library systems to
enable widespread access to it we are
key partners in the world of the
intellectual property concerns of
offering materials and MOOCs so and I
think that is one thing that's impressed
our faculty and the EDX folks is the
ability for libraries to collaborate
with one another so very my last the end
of last summer we had started
collaborating with our library
colleagues at all the edx partner
institutions and you have working groups
informed and work we're informing EDX
and our part on our institutions to its
around these kinds of issues are on
research skills intellectual property
and it and i would say that in our old
organizational structure do not wouldn't
pull this off so quickly it's a it's
because we're able to think about
institutional priorities in a different
way and we're not tied into a
long-standing organization that we've
been able to be more responsive than we
were in the past and i'm going to stop
there and i think next is questions
thank you very much and on all invite
both of our presenters to sit up front
hair to take questions did you get back
to talking about the two schools that
turned out to want to have struggle
relationships in their library and I
don't think didn't return back to it
sorry about that i'm not sure that you
did the two schools were on the School
of Architecture and planning and School
of Humanities Arts and Social Sciences
and so we're working on and they just
had really tight relationships with the
administration of those libraries and
we're working on rebuilding those
relationships with filling people now in
place so but we're consciously doing it
rather than having it based in an
organizational structure hi how this
question is for Marta and I'm interested
to know about what sort of maybe
surveying or assessment you may have
done in advance of building the space
about what students might be looking for
or hoping for yeah the library
administration did and I think about a
year or so of a assessment and before
the design work with the architectural
firm actually happened and they they I
believe brought back a faculty member
from retirement to do some focus groups
or interviews especially with faculty
and maybe some graduate students we
didn't do much assessment directly with
undergraduates although
we did create a research Commons demo
space right behind our reference desk
area in the open space and that allowed
us to observe how students might
interact with some new furniture and
some new configurations of study space
and then they created a number of I
forget what we were called working teams
to deal with different functions of the
library so I headed a working team that
was supposed to consider design of a
multifunction service desk they didn't
actually end up doing what we suggested
but that but the idea was that that we
were dreaming about what would be the
ideal kind of situation and giving it to
them and some of the contribution you
can see coming through in what actually
came to pass other things like the
reference desk are perplexing in the way
that they came to because we we knew
already in 2006-2007 that we needed more
flexibility in our reference um space so
that we weren't tied to a desk and what
we got was it an enormous fixed desk in
a very very silent space with bouncy
acoustics so we get shush 20 have a
reference interaction that we have to
yell across the desk so certain it's
hard to know exactly where the breakdown
happens there and there could be a lot
of really good reasons why that happened
there are lots of trade-offs in a huge
renovation project so you're not going
to get it right you just aren't but yes
we did try to gather information ahead
of time thank you for your out of your
excellent talks I'm just curious um but
with it the way that you approach this
if you could talk a little bit about
training and development for librarians
you talked martyr about the curse
librarians and having these new
positions do they have a role in sort of
developing others on staff for what what
did that relationship were cooking and
Tracy kind of similarly with these new
roles and new responsibilities how did
you configure the development of your
current staff
okay um actually in the first year of
our reorganization we one of the common
goals we had was that every liaison
would think about we had established the
common ground of liaison work to start
with by coming up with what we thought
were the optimal planner characteristics
they really didn't program and we asked
each liaison to think about their
program and doing the self-evaluation
really of where they thought their
strengths and weaknesses were and to set
a goal around what aspect of their work
they wanted to improve and then we and
it turned out many people had similar
things they wanted to work on so we
brought them together and created some
help for them to do that we had a Chris
department retreat soon after I became
the head and we did a lot of the reorg
work together to figure out we already
had been given a new leadership model
before we had had one unit head with
everybody in the department reporting
directly to the head and then we created
a team structure within so in the course
of the retreat we talked a lot about who
had expertise in what areas and and how
could we work together to kind of
maximize what we were able to accomplish
together but then bringing in new
librarians we tried to come up with
training series orientations but also
I'm collection development and for those
who had done collection development in
the same intensive way that we had and
obviously zooey being coming from the
faculty side the stock side of things
had experienced the reference
interaction
had experienced collections and so on
but hadn't actually done it so we teamed
her up with as I said we have a lot of
long-term very experienced librarian so
we had had the in-house expertise and
came up with training programs that way
most often one-on-one but sometimes in
small groups okay I'm there we go you
both talked quite a bit about big change
but you each also mentioned incremental
change and so is wondering if you could
talk a bit more about how you're
approaching incremental change what kind
of support you're getting from above and
from below to do incremental change and
sort of where that's going and how your
sis systematically approaching
incremental change well um we're trying
things out now so i think i mentioned
that we tried out a reference in the
research common space or maybe i didn't
mention it it was in my notes to mention
it so program forgive me if i'm
repeating myself but um so we actually
tried since there's not a desk in there
and we've been wanting to move away from
research reference services on the desk
we tried it out in the research Commons
and you know tried sitting in one
particular location tried another
location tried you know adding a sign
here's a librarian um tried other kinds
of things wearing late so we've tried
little things and we failed we really
didn't have much uptake but we learned
out of that um you know we could observe
while we were sitting there we could
have conversations with people who came
through kind of looking places sit down
and say you know what are you trying to
do maybe you actually don't need to be
here maybe what you need is the
librarian who's sitting at the desk over
there or or you need me right now so we
did learn a lot in that process so we've
been trying to encourage that I guess my
role is the unit head has
to really get people to try things out
and there's been a lot of fear of I
think in the past because of that
culture of perfectionism people had
ideas but they didn't end up going
anywhere and they got discouraged and
stopped and so I've been trying to
foster more of that go ahead give it a
try you know let's see what works mm et
the incremental change has been we've
been encouraging staff to put forward
proposals and ideas that come to them
through various user interactions or
whatever and bring them to me or to
upper management and and see what
happens and actually there's been a lot
of success with moving proposals through
to completion the other way is you know
anytime there's a vacancy is another way
that we're content the department head
level for sure but any vacant position
and enables us to think differently
about how we accomplish various things
and to implement change at that time and
there is regular attrition so um we have
ample opportunity to do that and one
other thing that I didn't mention looks
like families trying to cut a sock see
um is we're trying to also focus a lot
more on community building rather than
at building an individual's expertise so
we hired a librarian who also came from
a faculty position into a subject
specialist position and she's an
award-winning teacher and so we put her
to work offering pedagogy workshops a
stage series of pedagogy workshops
designed for librarians that could
really get us to think about what's your
teaching philosophy how you identify
learning outcomes how do you know if
you've actually achieved those learning
outcomes in the course of a class and so
on and that's been really new and
building a lot of community around these
things yeah we had one question down
front here so I was I knew Zoe borovsky
actually at the University of Oregon
when when
we were both on the faculty there years
ago so it was very interesting to hear
about the the I mean I remember when she
first left and this reminds me of is in
the humanities in general and also quite
specifically in history and in
literature there's a lot of attention in
graduate education on thinking about how
graduates with PhDs can go on to non
teaching positions not simply because oh
there aren't enough jobs but actually
looking at as a half-full glass not a
half-empty glass of thinking about the
wide range of careers that are that are
actually accessible and appropriate for
people with a PhD in the humanities so
what it makes me wonder about is since
you just mentioned two different staff
librarians who are now who have who do
not have MLS's do you see this then as a
possible major development of the future
do you see it as a sort of a temporary
anomaly because of the digital
humanities the way it's being worked in
the Academy or I mean have you did other
people on campus think about this kind
of general perspective that I'm
mentioning yeah I'm a third one I don't
have an MLS myself I came in as a
postdoc and yeah we talk about this all
the time and and for me it's less about
the whether or not you have an MLS or or
oh I would rather not hire people with
mlss I think that's the wrong way to
look at it it's more we're all better if
we have more variety and diversity of
expertise and so you know for one
position it might be really attracted to
look for somebody who has a JD because
we need legal expertise in in libraries
now for another position it might be
coming with an MBA because we also need
to really think about ourselves in the
way we present ourselves and market
ourselves in ways that we're not strong
in if we only hire people that have the
same credentialing so so that's the way
we've really approached it at UCLA so I
would say then as you deal with the
graduate populations which of course are
at ample at UCLA that that thought might
come across to them as
in their graduate education to keep on
horizon as one of the things that are
open there better possible for them in
the future yeah the history department
has started offering a alt ACK
alternative academic I'm workshops for
their grad students and I invite me
fairly often few those actually at this
point I'd like to kind of expand our
discussion and maybe loop back to some
of this morning sessions we have both of
our presenters Malcolm Brown and Roger
Sean Felder both here and of course one
of our faculty panelists are here so
we'd invite you to also ask questions
that may touch back to some of the
issues related to pedagogy some of the
changes in higher education and some of
the research findings that Roger
presents it hi Marta mentioned the
important need in point of for outreach
various of the of the presentations as
well as the entire theme of the
conference is the you know what's going
to happen to be in the future how do you
as library as librarians at top
universities you know top research
oriented universities relate to the
earlier panel the statements made by the
humanists the humanities professor who
was who is a meaty ablest medieval
specialists that you know the library is
incredibly important because of the you
know the physical and tactile and
working with original materials whereas
the two scientists had a kind of a
wistful attitude to torture to the
library as something of the pass
something that was incredibly important
to them as students and at least one of
them said well it's really important for
students or maybe someone else said that
but you know kind of where are we going
and think of some of the data-driven
social scientists let's you know just to
name one economists maybe they're going
to be more like the
the scientists and maybe in a little
while almost all of the humanists will
will also be in that and I'll leave it
at that and throw it to you both I can I
can start um I one of the benefits of
having a department that brings together
all the liaison librarians together is
that I get to see the kind of range of
needs that are in existence out there in
the community and like Roger pointed out
there's some common needs across very
disparate disciplines that they may
manifest themselves a little different
but at the core there's some similar
needs so so we're reacting to some of
that in a way like our research data
management services group now contains
not only the social science data
librarian who we've had for a long time
you have some science and engineering
librarians in there who are focusing on
data for part of their time we are now
working on bringing in a digital
humanities perspective as well to kind
of get in that common need will also pay
attention to the diverse needs of those
different communities so I think there's
a variety of ways to think about it yeah
I guess I'll mention this North Campus
research community study that we're
doing North Campus being on on UCLA
campus to social sciences humanities
side of campus south campuses the hard
sciences and one of the things that
we're doing is interviewing faculty
individual faculty members and asking
them how do you train your graduate
students in your field to become you to
hop like what do scholars in your field
need and what are you doing within your
own departments to train them and then
what role do you see the library having
an asst but we always ask them how are
you trained and how is that different
than what your ski runs using and that
gives them enough
you need to reflect on well things were
so different but well now how I do my
research is this or that or I actually
wish that I had time to think about this
or that so so that's been a really
productive conversation for us to have
and as you said different disciplines
are going to have different answers to
that and so if anything is clear.its
that there's not a one-size-fits-all
kind of way to do outreach so I think
it's very similar to what you're saying
hi I just had a question about the
proliferation of online universities
that we were talking about this morning
um I know that some of them have been
considered like diploma mills and I was
wondering if employers are familiar with
which online universities are less
reputable and does it present a
disadvantage or vonage for the workforce
on to having an online university
university degree versus a more
traditional degree we can get a mic too
I don't know how to talk about the
Pullman Mills so much because the online
programs at least that were watching do
not described as diploma Mills they're
serious attempts at providing
post-secondary education so I think I
think what's happening i think one of
the things that we've seen with all this
stuff going on the MOOC is that because
there's now an EDX the elite
institutions have have kind of put their
blessing on all an education or so
saying we're getting into this pond now
too so in certain in a certain way what
we see over the past several years is a
new legitimacy for online education a
matter of fact we've been delivering
online education for a long time even
going back as far as correspondence
courses we've been doing it at a
distance so I think the big ship is that
it's become more legitimate it's become
more seemly if you will to look down
these paths and see how can we actually
serve other constituencies that might
not have had advantage or access to the
set of education before a comment for
Roger Schoenfeld it is very
crude way of helping historians and well
2222 things that I've discovered that i
think are that are very useful one is
that don't take for granted that that
every faculty member on your campus
knows that there is someone who can help
them with their with their discipline
and I found we have this this I don't
know if it's new it was newly made
available to on set I'd yell this I TS
messaging system where you can actually
you can actually select a group of
individuals like all posts in the
humanities or all may all English majors
and it's and it's updated daily in real
time and you can actually you can slice
and dice these you know any way you like
and you can actually write to people and
I found that that made that made that
that alone just that one step which was
introduced to the last year or so made a
huge difference because then all of a
sudden everybody has an email from you
and it's sitting in their box I'm so
whenever I hear from somebody else it
always says you know welcome back from
Yale library that's the subject line
because it's what I said to them you
know that's because that now they know
who I am and then they'll you know
they'll ask me any number of questions
and it's unconvinced it this is a sea
change up in there 12 years and and you
know it's like all of a sudden you know
everybody knows who you are and it's so
much different from just you know
sending something out to a listserv or
asking a secretary send it out it's a
direct communication they know who you
are and they it's some somehow it's more
tangible a connection I don't know I
thought that was my feeling about the
other thing is about in terms of the the
massive amount of literature keeping up
one thing that you can that I discovered
you can do with Voyager is is you can
create an RSS feed using specific call
number ranges and I've done that in the
hopes of the English program among
others will put it up on their on their
page now that relies on them knowing yrs
tactical numbers knowing what rrsp dozen
for that what could what it do for them
but that is an option if you could find
a way to publicize to create it in a
public
that would help people to keep up with
the Lisa monographic literature I
actually have a question if I could just
jump in for Malcolm and it was really
interesting to hear about some of the
trends that you have been you know
looking at exploring and monitoring at
Columbia were often think of ourselves
as primarily a graduate focused
institution with the many graduate
programs we have and so I wondered what
kinds of trends may be different or what
what research is saying about at that
level the models and approaches that
that may be shifting well that's that's
a very good question a lot of the stuff
we've been watching and trying to track
obviously with undergraduate education
and let's see with graduate education
itself but I think I one thing that we
are definitely seeing is that there is
new emphasis on I think it's come out
here several times and in the
conversations that have taken place
today is sort of this new emphasis of
not of helping the graduate students
understanding the role of educators I
think all our institutions some other
ways at the top or soar in the middle of
the pack wherever you are I think we're
all going back and looking at our
teaching mission with a lot more care
than we have in the past a lot of times
it's been almost an afterthought I know
it's not popular to say that but I think
it's true and so I think you're seeing
that that new dedication of the new
renewal a new focus on the teaching
mission happening at all layers of the
institution not just thinking how can we
teach our graduate students better we're
really trying to get them into the loop
preparing them as teaching professionals
as we go forward so that is certainly
another sort of shift that we're we're
noticing is the role the graduates in
the teaching mission of the institution
if I could just put in a plug at acrl
also i'll be on a panel with joan
lippincott from CN I and Bertha Chang
from ncsu libraries about graduate
student research and teaching needs
Friday
well I guess we're coming right up to
our our time to close and I'd like to
give a sincere thanks to all the
presenters on the high quality
and I'd also like to thank our sponsors
for helping make this event possible and
all of the volunteers who worked very
hard to pull together all the details so
thanks again all for attending